ではよろしくお願いします
あのダンマパダというテキストを読んでいますが
今日このダンマパダというテキストの番目の偈です
ヤタアピ・バマロー・プッパン・ワンナワン・ワンナ・ガンダン・アヘッティャン・パレーティ・ラサ・マーダーヤ・エーワン・ガーミ・ムニー・チャリー
ヤタアピ・バマロー・プッパン・ワンナ・ガンダン・アヘッティャン・パレーティ・ラサ・マーダーヤ・エーワン・ガーミ・ムニー・チャリー
今日の偈はそれほど難しい意味はございませんと思います
ヤタアピ・バマロー・プッパン
バマローというのはあれ
何でしたっけ？ミツバチですね
プッパンというのは花のこと
ワンナ・ガンダン・アヘッティャン
ワンナというのは花の色
ガンダっていうのは花の香り
アヘッティャンっていうのは
そこはもう傷害しないで
壊さないでっていうことで
花の美しさも香りも壊すことなく
そちらに迷惑かけることなく
このミツバチがね パレーティ・ラサ・マーダーヤ
ラサン・アーダーヤ ラサンというのはもうこの花の大事なものですね
いわゆる何ですかね 蜜ですね
ラサンというのは味ということでもあるし
おいしいという意味でも使っているし
エッセンスという意味でも使うし
自分に必要なものっていうことなんですね
それをアーダーヤ 持ってパレーティ
出て行く もうずっと この偈のもう3分の2
もうただミツバチのことを言ってるんですよ
ミツバチは花の香りにも花的美しさにも
何にも障害 迷惑 邪魔をすることなく
蜜だけを持って出て行くんです
エーワン・ガーミ・ムニー・チャリー
ムニーというのは仙人のこと
聖者のこと あるいは比丘のことなんですね
そのように村に歩くんだと
で 仏教的な言葉 それたった4分の1だけなんですけど
で 村に歩くっていうことは
托鉢に出るっていう意味なんですね
出家する人々 特にインドのね
当時のたくさんね 宗教の方々が出家していましたし
仏教だけではなかったしね
いろんな宗教がございまして
で 出家する人々は一応托鉢して生活をする
だからインドでは托鉢することというのは
それから宗教 修行する人々に何かを施すということは
一般的な習慣というかね
そんなに珍しいことではありません
ヒンドゥー教でもだいたい一般のインド文化では
相手は誰であろうと何かあげた方がいいということで
特にこの客に対して すごい接待するんですね
全くもう知らない人なんですけど
人が来たらまあ何の怖がることもなく
必要なものは全部してあげるんですよ
泊まらせてあげるし ご飯作ってあげるし
必要なものがあったら何でもしてあげるという習慣があるんですね
別に 客ということだけだから
客だから別に名前なんとかもしれないし
どこから来たかもしれないし
別に予約入れてきたわけでもないしね
で 知らない方が村に来たら
その人の必要なことをしてあげるっていうのは普通の
文化なんですね ヒンドゥー教になってくると
もうアティティデワという神様だと
アティティはアティティっていうのは客ですね
客っていうのは神様であるという言葉がありまして
これは日本でも同じ言葉がありますけどね
意味は違いますけどね
まあこちらにどんな大事な教えでも
こちらに回っちゃうと
かなり意味が逆に逆さまになりますからね
まあそれでその文章を見てもわかるように
で インド人にとっては神様っていうのはお供えをすることで
尊敬することで だからもう神様っていうのは見えるものじゃないし
もし客として知らない人が来たならば
これがもう神様ですと
だからその人から何か見返りとかに金儲かるとかね
そういうっていうのはもう全く考えていないし
成り立たない ただ自分が自分の家で尊敬
信仰している神様にするお供えやら全部その人にやってあげる
神様にお供えすると ちょこちょこっとほんのちょっとしたものを供えするかもしれませんけど
ちゃんと人間だから その場合はもっと腕を振って
もっと人間に必要な量を差し上げなくちゃいけないんですね
だからまあ 必要なものは
もしその人がね  沐浴したい状態であるならば
そのことでもしてやってあげちゃうし
そういうことをいろいろ何でもやってあげるんです
それで全く知らない人々に親切してくれると
もう相手が何かちょっと申し訳なくなるかもしれませんだけど
その時は別にあんた客でしょうと一言言えば
もうそれでお互いに精進するんですね
それは私が偉いんだから
私のことを随分大事にしてくれるわけではなくて
もう客として扱っているんだと
客っていうのはもう神様ではないかと
だから自分もすごい穏やかな気持ちで
その家族を祝福してあげなくちゃいけないんですね
自分はただ旅人であることを知ってますけど
その場合はもうその神の
代表になってしまったんだから
もうその気持ちで家族を養育しなくちゃいけないんだと
そうしなくてはもう大変悪いということになっちゃうんだと
そういうことで まあ一応
客に対する一生懸命面倒を見るということっていうのは
まあ一般的な文化的なことになっています
だから托鉢して生活するっていうことも一般的で
なことで珍しいことではないんです
そこでヒンドゥー教ではこの客になることね
あるいは旅をすることもヒンドゥー教でも大事な行為であってっていうことで
旅をすればするほど その人はもう知らないことは勉強できて
知らない先生たちに出会って
知らないところに入って修行できてとかね
まあそういうことで このいっぱい自分の人間として自分が経験得て深めるのではないかという考え方があります
で そういうことでバラモン人も結構旅をしたりはする
バラモン人の場合はもう
まあ結局金持ちの人々もいるし
まあそれでもまあ旅に出たら何も持っていかない
何も持っていかないでただ旅に出る
インドは一応大きい国ですので
かなり 時間かかる作業なんですね
日帰りで旅するわけじゃないんです
年帰りとかね 年帰りとか
そういう風なスケジュールで行かなくちゃいけないんですね
例えばもう中央インドから北の方にヒマラヤまで行くぞと思ったら
これはまあまあ年がかりの作業になるんです
とにかく歩いていく そこでこのヒンドゥー教でよく見られることっていうのは
この その修行に入る人が
もう勝手に自分勝手に神様にいろいろ約束契約するんですね
神様にも何とか何とかお供えを奉仕しますよとかね
で またもしかすると結構お金かかるものもかもしれません
それで自分がずっとインドをあっちこっち歩いて歩いて
もう私はこういう約束で
神様に年終わったところで儀式をやるという約束で歩いてますよと
だからお金ちょうだいということで人々が集まるんですね
まあ例えばもう万ぐらいかかる何かお供えを自分勝手に決める
自分は全然お金何も持ってない
それで片っ端から歩いて歩いて歩いて
もうお金やらいろんな財産から集めて
まあ真面目な人はそのお供えをするし
そうでない人はそれはそれなりにまあなんとかするでしょうね
だからまあそこはまあ商売にしたりする人々も結構いる
また 家族の面倒見るような仕事をするのはもういやいや面倒くさいと思っている男たちも平気で私はもう修行に出るぞと言って修行に出るんでして
もう人のご飯タダで食って
まあタダで泊まってもらって
もう好き勝手にもう何年もいて
またもう家のことを思い出したらまた戻ってきてという
もう家族はどうやってるか
何食べてるか 全然もう気にしない
まあそういうこともまあ
また一般人がもうとにかく寄付をする
それはもう在家生活の仕事の中で一部になっている
で 神様にもお供え物お布施しなくちゃいけないし
アティティという客にもしなくちゃいけないし
また乞食にも何かあげなくちゃいけないっていうことは
日常生活の在家の仕事の中のスケジュールの一部なんですね
自分儲かったものは自分だけで食べてやるぞっていうことは
インド文化ではないんです
そういうことだから もう乞食の人々も乞食カーストが出来立ったりして
またその中でもいろいろ芸を見せてものをもらったりとかね
まあいろんな人々はいるんですね
ちょっと猿回しをしたり
別に日本で言ってるような
ドイツでやっているような大道芸人ということじゃないんです
もう大した芸もないんですけど
似ているといえば似ているんですけど
何か楽器を奏でてお金を要求する
ああいう人々は ある一種の乞食カーストなんです
だからこちらのカメラでインドの大道芸人文化は大変発達した
あれ大道大道芸人ってなんでもないんです
あんなものは芸でもなんでもないんだけどね
まあ子供からもうそこを修行させてるんだから
それなりにはやってるかもしれませんだけどね
だから子供も三歳四歳になってくると芸を教えちゃう
そうするとかなり儲かるんだということで
子供に教育とかそんなのはない
あっちこっち行かないと
大道芸人という人々も人が集まる日にちありますよ
全インドでいろんなところでお祭りやる日にちがありますから
そういうとこ そういう時
自分に歩ける距離で で
全国を歩けることは誰にもできませんだからね
自分の州の中でも半分以上は一年中歩くと
それで金儲けてもう子供は育ったから結婚して
またその子供にまた教えたりとかね
まあそういうふうな それは一応乞食グループの一部なんですね
何か芸を見せて歌を作ってあげて
猿回しやら蛇のなんとかとかね
あるいはマジックとか何とかして
アクロバティックもありますしね
まあなんとかかんとか芸を見せてお金をもらったりとか
とにかくこの お釈迦様から見れば
お釈迦様の家柄から見れば
この一番惨めな生き方なんです
シャカ族はものすごいプライド高くて
バラモン人も全然相手にしない
バラモン人って自分たちの家の家来カーストだと家来でしたからね
一応 で 自分たちは 人に何かちょうだいっていうその一言葉は絶対言わない
いかなる場合でも 飢えて死にかけていても言わないんです
そうは飢えているんだから
何か食べるものはないんでしょうかと
それぐらいプライドはあるんです
ご飯食べなかったら 自分が何かそれなりの何か仕事をして
これを仕事するんだから
これにはこれぐらいやと
で それでも仕事してもらって
向こうはもうくれなかったら
まあそれでまた文句は言わない
向こうはもうそういうカーストだから
もう人間としての約束を守るわけじゃないんだから
まあいいやということで気にしないんですね
だから釈族はもうその家の人々というのは乞食やることっていうのはもう信じられることじゃないんです
その習慣としては しかし
インド文化ではもうごく一般的な当たり前の一つの文化なんです
そこでお釈迦様があえてこの乞食生活を決めたんですね
それだけでもブッダに人間として見てみると
もうできる仕事じゃないんです
現代の方々は家のプライドということは全然わからないかもしれませんだけど
これかなりきついもんなんですよ
そう簡単に変えることはできないんです
頭で分かっても もう動かないんですよ
体は 自分の家でやらないことっていうのはね
家でけしからんことを惨めなことをやってる風に決めてるものっていうのは
もう他の悪い仲間に入ってやりましょうと言ったっても
これできないんですよ
ですから これはまあお釈迦様は王子でありましたしね
普通の釈族でもないし
その中でも高家でしょうし
で 托鉢をすることになりますね
最初は出家して ほとんどもうご飯食べなかったみたいですよ
食欲ないんです しかしもう死んでしまいますから
もう悟り真理を発見しようと思って出家したんだからね
まあどうしようもない時はちょこっと托鉢には出る
それでも最初にもらったご飯見たら
見たところでお腹がものすごくもう逆に回ってきて
もう吐き出しそうになったと
ご飯を見て いかに気持ち悪かったということなんです
食べるところじゃない
何て美味しいご飯でしょうかっていう話じゃないんです
お腹がものすごくぐるぐる回って
もう吐けそうになってしまった
で見ることさえもできなかったんですよ
それぐらいきついんですよ
で その時は私は何のために出家したんでしょうかと
何のために宮殿を出たんでしょうかと
何のために全ての親戚も親も家族も捨てたんでしょうかと
それで家のプライドとかね
今までごっつい贅沢なものを食べていたんだからとか
そういう自我を捨てるためではないかと
思って口に入れたんですけど
口に入れる入れるたびに
もう体が強烈に拒絶反応を起こしちゃったりして
まあそれからはものすごい長い間断食ばっかしでね
断食やめた時はもう托鉢ではなくてね
スジャータというものすごい金持ちの女性の方がね
豪華な料理を作ってお布施したんですけど
で それは何の遠慮もなく召し上がりましたけど
それからはまた 7週間ご飯を召し上がらなかったんですね
49日間 それはまあお釈迦様の人生で悟ってからはもうご飯美味しいっていうことではなくて
自分が貧しい人々のものを頂いた方が
その人々には多大な幸福になるんだ
なるんだぞっていうことで
人々にとにかく幸福 徳を与えてあげるために
単なる慈しみで 慈悲で
ご飯を召し上がったりはしたんです
それでも微妙で ほんのわずかでも一言葉言われたら
その人から一生ご飯は食べない
あなたにご飯をお布施したいんですけど
それなりに資格あり あんた真面目にいるのかよ
それぐらいでも一言葉言われたら
その人には説法する 私は資格あるんだよと
私にしか資格ないんだよと
人に恵みを与える資格はね
しかし あなたのご飯は食べませんと
そんな乞食じゃないんだと
歌ってさば回しをして帽子を回していくらかちょうだいって
そういうワニばかじゃないんだと
それでお釈迦様は弟子たちもできて
5人比丘たちと これから 60人のヤサさんのという金持ちのごっちゃまが出家してね
若者で そこから若者がたくさん出家しちゃって
それからカッサパというね
そちら 1,000人 他の宗教の行者たちもね
入って もうこのグループ
お釈迦様より年上なんですね
ヤサさんとのその 45人が若者で
で そこお釈迦様にいろいろ何でも言えるんです
もうカッサパのグループはもうみんな年上の人々
しかしそちら全部まとめて 1,000人ですよ
で たちまちこうやってもうたくさん弟子たちも出てきて
で 父親が一応ずっと お釈迦様の父親がもう出て行ったんだからって忘れたことはないんですよ
ずっと調べるんですよ
いろいろ方法で もうメッセンジャーというかね
こういう使材を送ったりして
もうとにかく調べる 息子はどこにいるのか
何をやっているのかとかね
決して 1 日も忘れたことはない
苦行に入っていた時でも
ものすごく心配で心配で
よく調べるんですよ もう終わったんでしょうか
終わったんでしょうかと
で 終わってというのは
とにかくこの自分の息子はもう真理を発見するんだと
舐めたいとの子供じゃないんだと
負けるものじゃないんだというすごい信頼があったんです
だから仏の王子にいたって王様にしたっても
ここ不遜の人だからね
苦行して悟るでしょうと
思ってて もう他のインドで誰にもできないほど厳しい呼吸をしていたんだからね
うちの息子は必ず成功するぞとずいぶんもう信じてはいたんですけど
もう死にかけちゃったんです
三回も で 倒れちゃって
まあそれでも神々も一応チェックしていたんです
神々見てもまあもうわからなくなっちゃって
やっぱり死んでるんだと
仮死状態になっちゃって
で スッドーダナ王子のこの神々が報告したんだと
まあ神々は信じたくなければ
結局は王様が自分では連絡取れるように
もう息子にもう知られないように
シッダールタ王子に知られないように一応調べてはいたんです
それで亡くなったっていう連絡を得たら
息子はもう悟り開きましたかと
いえ 修行中でしたと で
うちの息子は死ぬわけないんだと
目的に達しないでね 死ぬわけじゃないんだよ
いくら言ってももう生きがないんだと
見て調べていたんだよ
神々を追い出したと あなた方にはわからないんだと
それぐらい自分の息子のことを信頼していたんですよ
それで もう悟ったっていうことを聞いたら
まあ一番喜ぶのは一応まあ父親でしょう
喜んで まあよかったよかった
ではもう自分の国に戻ってもらうぞと
もう悟り開いたんだからね
もう家に戻ってももういいんじゃないかと
いうことで もうすっと宮殿から人々を送るんですよ
戻ってくださいと というか
自分の国にもそこら辺に歩くんじゃなくてね
私の国に来てちょうだいと
でて行く行く人々はみんなもう行ってお釈迦様に自分たちの皇太子でしょうし
だから行って礼をして挨拶をして
もういきなりは言えないし
自分たちにはそんな覚悟があるわけではないし
で まあ機会を見てようではないかということで
お釈迦様と一緒にいて
もう結局は出家してしまうんです
出家してもう修行に入っちゃうんです
出家して修行に入って
まあ出家の仕事じゃないんだけど
この在家の色々事付けをね
出家たるものは在家の事付けで言ったりはしないんだぞということで言わないんです
で また困ってまたまでまた送ってもまた同じことで
そこでこのお友達がいて
もうお釈迦様の遊び仲間がいて
子供の頃 これが一応大臣格の人で
お釈迦様の遊び仲間なんですね
その人に言ったんです
その人は来たくなかったんですけど
シッダールタ王子は君のもう友達でしょう
一応 ずっと一緒に遊んでいたでしょうに
だからもう遊び仲間だから何でも言うんじゃないかと
だからこちらに来るように言ってくださいと
言ったら もうそのカールって言う大臣ですけど
まあ行くことは行くんだけどね
しかし私はこれっきり帰らないや
出家するんだと それで私は仕事を辞めさせてもらって
出家許可するならば彼には出家できないんですよ
もう政府政治やってますから
解錠できるのは王様なんですね
私は職業から解錠してくれるならば
まあ言いますよ ったらやっぱりどれほど息子が来て欲しがったということは
まあいいよということで
大臣をね 大臣格を解錠してあげて
君はこれっきり復帰でもいいと
決して離したくなかった人なんです
息子の代わりにもうすごい可愛がっていたんです
その人は行って もう何のことなくもう出家許可しているし
ます出家して修行出て悟り開いて
それでもうお釈迦様ある程度お友達でもあるんだからね
で 長い文章で自分の国をね
褒め称えるんですよ シャカ族っていうのは
その国っていうのはね
とても美しいんだよと
まあお釈迦様がいたところよりはものすごい美しいんですよ
この住んでいたところっていうのは
天気もよろしくて もう山々があって
水が綺麗な水がいっぱいあって
すごい厳しいところにいるんですよ
あのバラナシとかね そういうところはね
当時では一番インドで発展
発展していた街でしたけどね
それでも環境はそんなにいいわけじゃないし
だからまあ信じられないほど美しい環境で美しい世界だと
また今の時期だったらね
もう花の咲いて 柔らかい葉っぱいっぱい出てきて
なんて素晴らしいでしょうかというふうに言うとお釈迦様が自分の友達が何言おうかということをわかったんですね
わかって わかりました
じゃあみんなで行こうってことに
行くことに決めたんです
大体この時期でしたけどね
行ったのは それで弟子たちみんな連れて
まあ父親が自分のこと見せびたがっていたんだからね
まあいっぱい弟子たちを一緒に行ったんですね
まあ行ったら まあすごい大祭りで
お釈迦様を迎えて説法も聞いて
しかし 次の日はお釈迦様は托鉢に出たんです
自分の自分の街に 普段人に顔も合わせない
普通 まあ再起でいた時は
まあどこへ行っても白いパラソルを付けていたみたいですね
自由時間 普通の人にはそう軽々く直接話すことを許すってなかったんですよ
それで家から家托鉢に出たんですよ
で 父親がものすごいショック受けちゃってね
いくらなんでもそれは何やと
私たちはそういう家じゃないでしょうと
それはもうあなたの家はそうなんですけど
私たちの家柄はこういうものだと
ブッダの世界は托鉢して生活する世界だと
もう家は変わったと これは習い
習いの家やと だから仏教ではこの托鉢するっていうことは大変なことで
まあ特にシャトリア族の人々にとっては
もうこれできたもんじゃないんですよ
で 結構シャトリア族の王家の人々はもう結構出家しましたしね
出家した人は誰でも托鉢しなくちゃいけない
これ デイヴァダッタももうなんで贅沢に溺れたかというと
まあそれの人 それなんですよ
托鉢したくないんですよ
それもあったんです こんなみっともないことは
もうどうやってもできないんだと
言ってアジャセ王に脅して
毎日宮殿からご飯もらっちゃうんです
宮殿でも用意して もう 100人でも 200人でも 300人の分でも作っておくんです
托鉢には出ない それでももう食い物ばっかり狙っている一般のだらしない連中はそちらにつくという
食べ物がありますよ 人格のある
他の人々はもう食べ物を狙って出家するわけじゃなくて
財産捨てて出家するんだから
もうそんなことは全く気にならない
お釈迦様のところに入るんですね
サーリプッタ尊者のところに入って出家するんです
一番だらしない この格好つけたくてね
もう楽贅沢して楽々に生きていたいために
人々に尊敬してもらいたいために出家した連中があちらに入っていて
だいぶだってのは結構グループができちゃったんですね
そちらがお釈迦様が認めない行為ばっかりやって
一般の人々が来ると飛んで行って挨拶するわ
もう歓迎するわ もうあれやこれやとかね
とにかく人の機嫌をいかに取るかということに必死で
これでみるみるうちに人気者になってしまうんですね
で 心清らかにする作業っていうのは
ものすごい まあコツコツと下向きでやらなくちゃいけないことなんですけど
それじゃなくて なんとかよりもなんかこの神父牧師になったような感じなんですね
神父の作業 牧師の仕事を
そういうことで もう一般人の機嫌を取っていかに教会に引き寄せるのかという
自分たちは別に修行を下向きで修行する必要はないんですね
それでも毎日戒律は増えるはもう大変でしたけどね
デーヴァダッタさんの場合でも
やっぱり托鉢したくなかった気持ちぐらいはわかりますよ
お辞儀だけはやりたくないんだと
お釈迦様のことを嫌いでしたわけじゃないんですよ
いろいろもう気に入らんことはありましたけど
だからといって もう大胆にもう敵だ
悪魔だ 嫌いだということはなくて
本人もやっぱり真面目に出家して修行したかったんです
ブッダの教えを知りたかったんです
ですが もうライバルでもあるんだから
もう何でも言う通りに入りたくないところもあるんですね
それでも托鉢だけはもうこれはもうやりたくないということ
それで怒ったのは お釈迦様がこの経典からこのご飯に対して
これはもう排泄物やっていうかね
吐いたものだと 嘔吐物と言ったんです
あのデーヴァダッタ あれ嘔吐物食べてる人でしょという風に人々が
嘔吐物です なんて言ったっけ
うん 一体 すごい言葉でしょ
いくらなんでもあれ義理の兄弟で
ヤショーダラ夫人の弟でしょ
これが腹が立って 家柄のプライドや托鉢には出てきて出たくない人に
あいつはあれ嘔吐物食べてる
それでお釈迦様にいろいろね
企みを ずっとそれからなんであれこれと頑張ったのは
暗殺してやるぞとかね
だから別にお釈迦様はデーヴァダッタのことを別に思ってはいなかったんですよ
で 親戚というところとしては
そこで個人的に人間としては親切にしたいという気持ちはずっとあったんです
あったんですけど このご飯に対するこの釈尊のプライドはお釈迦様が守っていたんですよ
デーヴァダッタが釈尊がやってはいけないことをやっているんです
ちょっとごまかしをやって
まやかしをやって ご飯も美味しいご飯もらってるんですね
だからあれは嘔吐物と
お釈迦様の鉢に入るものは
もうたとえもう腐ったものであろうとも
あげる側がもうありがたく
どうか自分の輪廻が幸福でありますように
どうか受けてくださいというね
その人々が自分の幸福のためにあげたものであって
だからお釈迦様が逆に何かもらってるんじゃなくて
もう何億倍もその人々に返してるんです
まあそういうことで この食べ物の質じゃなくて
あの意味のね 宗教的な定義のこの意味で
まあアウトオブに言ってしまって
で そこまで托鉢のことを言いましたけど
まあそれでもう仏教の世界になってくると
お釈迦様は微妙にこの托鉢のことも考えたんですよ
いわゆる仏弟子としては
この惨めで乞食みたいな
そういう生活にはなってほしくない
出家だから社会とは関係ないんだよと
社会人よりも随分優れた立派な生き方をしている
だから托鉢しながら まあわかりやすく言えば乞食やりながら
王様よりも偉い格にいるという
で そういうことでも托鉢はインド文化と違って仏教的な托鉢っていうのはもう現れてきたんですね
仏教の托鉢って 仏弟子たちの托鉢って
それで普通は黙って歩く
一言葉も語らない 歩く時も瞑想である
まあ慈悲の瞑想か いろいろ瞑想お坊さんたちは一人一人でもう自分の瞑想っていうものが個人的に受けているんだから
まあそれも何でもよろしいし
瞑想である で 家の前にほんの少々の時間しか待たない
ずっともらうまで待ってるわけじゃないんです
まあ時間はまあ大体まあ一人の人が
まあ水 喉が渇いた人が水を飲むと
まあそれぐらいの時間なんですね
せいぜい 1分ぐらいかな
というか 牛のたとえで牛が水飲むぐらいの時間なんですね
まあ 1分ぐらいでしょうね
結構大量に牛飲む時は飲みますからね
1分以内ぐらいでいて
すぐにそれ次の家に行く
それから次の家に行く
それから家は決して飛ばしてはいけない
順番で行かなくちゃいけない
そういう気配は厳しい
だからこのあの家が本当に貧しいんだからと
まあやっぱりよしましょうって
それは禁止です ある例えば農民の人の家に行ったら
当然ご飯もちゃうし 次の
家はもう乞食がもうちっちゃな何て言いますか
屋根 葉っぱだけの屋根作って
そこでホームレスでいるかもしれませんよ
あ この方のところ申し訳ない
それはダメなんです そちらにも出すんです
同じ時間 で 飛ばしてはいいっていうのは
この異教で邪教で その上もうものすごく侮辱するんだったらね
物を投げたり悪口言ったりするならば
その家を飛ばしてもいいんです
しかし 宗教は違うんだけど
別に物を投げたり侮辱したりすることではなくて
文化 文化的な人間で そちらその宗教
こちらこの宗教でそれぞれやりましょうというふうな文化的な人間だったら
その家には待っている
その家の人はもう全く毎日来ても何もくれないかもしれませんけど
その決まってる時間はその家の前にも待つ
文化的な人間だったらではなくて
お前ら何あれやこれって言うんだったら
その家だけは飛ばすことは許してます
あるいはその家の人は我々宗教違いますから
あんた毎日来てね 家の前に座ってることは迷惑ですから
こちら止まらないでくださいと頼んだら
そこでOKなんです 本人に頼まれたんだから
その家は飛ばせる インド文化ではそれは言えないんです
それこそもう恥なんです
それこそ不可触 免触の人がやってることと同じくなっちゃうんです
社会からはみ出されている人間になりますから
言わないんです うちの家では待たないでくださいと
だからまあ 何かあげる
自分の国でもキリスト教の人でも托鉢なら托鉢しますよ
宗教はもうだらしない野蛮的な原始宗教を信奉しているかもしれませんだけど
人間はインド文化系の人間だから
そういうことはできないんです
もう坊主は悪魔の教えばっかり広げてるんだよと言うんですけど
面と向かっては言えることはできない
もうちゃんとお布施はする
言ったな わからない場合はちょっと困ったりして
どうすればいいかとかなんとか
知ってる人に聞いてでも一応そこら辺では問題ないんです
あのイスラム人さえもやりますからね
自分の国にいるイスラム人が
だからブッダのブッダの文化っていうのは結構強いんですよ
他の文化でそう簡単に潰すことはできないんです
そういうことで 托鉢に対してもすごい厳しいしきたりがありまして
で 喋ってはいけないし
何も言ってはいけないし
それで日本のお寺でも托鉢しますけど
例えばすすみたいなものを持っていて
チリンチリンあれはもう仏教やることじゃないんです
これはもうだらしないヒンドゥー教の人々
品格のないやり方 絶対品格が悪いと気持ちそこを見ると気持ち悪くなるんで
私には なんで惨めで品格ないことやってる
これ明らかに乞食がやってるんだと
でも日本でそういう習慣できたのは
別にそういう気持ちってわけではなくて
こちらの文化システムではね
まあそういうことでもしないと一般人が気づかないんだから
もう死体ばっかりでしょ
昔から だからもう総統で何が起きてるかさっぱりわからないしね
まあそういうことで 何かお経を大きい声で上げたりとかね
あるいはおりんを鳴らしたりしちゃうと
みんなもう托鉢来てるんだってことで
さっさとすごい丁寧にお布施はする
だから丁寧なお布施する気持ちはあるんですけど
もう 24時間もう死んでるんだから
ああいう何か音を立てないと
もうまあそれはそれでそうなってますけど
本当はそれもやってはいけないことなんです
別に日本人がお布施あげしたくないんだから
強引に奪ってるわけじゃないんです
みんなお布施したい気持ちはあるんです
あるんだけど こんなもう死体文化でね
生き生きしてないんだから
強引に言わない限りはもう動かないんですね
[咳]そこで比丘が家の前に1分以内ぐらいね 1
分ぐらい待って 信者さんにお布施したい気持ちあるならば
ちょこっとチャンスを与えるんだよと
それだけ 何あげるか あげる
あげるかあげないかということは
完全たるあげる側の自由なんです
だからあげる側が自分の子供にも自分も食べたいために作った料理全部片っ端からあげたってのは
後で文句言う権利はないんです
比丘が来たんだから 全部作った料理あげましたよと
なんて迷惑ですかと言うと
そのままそのご飯 はいどうぞと返すか捨てるか
もう食べません そういう権利はないんです
あげた人に だってあげた人は自分で決めるんだから
あげるかあげないか あげたくなければ
それで黙っていればいいんです
で そこはあの スリランカ文化は昔もうすごい托鉢文化はもう発達してましたし
ミャンマー タイだったら
今ももうもうごく一般的なことだからね
で 時々家の人々にとってはね
もう食べ物ある場合もない場合もいろいろバラバラ無茶苦茶だからね
だから自分の国ではあまり誰も意味のわからない単語がありまして
で もうあまりにも使い切っちゃって
単語自体がなまってるんですよ
シンハラ言語っていうのは
もともとサンスクリット言語がもうマザーランゲージなんですよ
そこから変わってるんだから
我々の言語でも これ何の意味かとわからない場合は
そのままサンスクリット語にするんですよ
サンスクリットにすれば
あ なるほど そういうことかってわかるんですよ
我々サンスクリットを知らなくても
自分喋ってる言語は一応サンスクリット語からもう変わっているもんなんです
でも あんまりにもこの東北弁やらもう鹿児島弁やらね
そういう風にあまりもなまっちゃうと
これ何やと日本語かということもわからなくなりますよ
でもギューッと調べると
鹿児島弁でも日本で日本語であることはわかるでしょうね
まあそういうもうあまりにも訛りかけている単語が一つありまして
それっていうのはもう何のために使うかというと
あるお坊さんが自分の家に立っているんだけど
自分の家にはもう作った料理はない
米あってもあげてはいけないんですよ
野菜あってもあげてはいけないんですね
あげてもそれは断るんです
生野菜 米 というものはもう絶対受けてはいけない
だからお布施だからといって何でもいいというわけじゃないんです
あれはもう大変 召使い奴隷とかいっぱいいたインドだから
自分に気に入ってるお坊さんに
このお坊さんももう一人で修行してるんだから
家にこのもう召使い一人いますから
お坊さん来い 飯 粥を使ってくださいとお布施しますと
で 他のものは私が見てあげます
受け取ってはいけないんです
動物も受け取りはいけないし
そうやってまあ受け取りはいけないリストもたくさんあります
だからまあ作った料理がなかったら信者さんはもう困りますしね
そうするともうそれがお坊さんに報告するんです
待っていたら悪いんだ
待たせたら悪いんだからね
その報告する単語があって
これはもうシンハラ語で皆様何の関係もないんですけど
アハラボーイという言葉なんですけど
誰もわからない これ何の意味でしょうかと
それで学者がむちゃくちゃこれ調べて調べて
まあどう見たってもサンスクリット語
パーリ語にも元がない
それでそれに入れ替えようとしたっても意味が出てこない
アハラっていうのはアーハランということで食べ物なんですね
ボーイっていう言葉はシンハラ語ではないんですけど
おそらくこれバフーとかというサンスクリット語
パーリ語ではないかなと
だからバフーターニアハーニ
バフーニアハーラニという単語がアーハラ
アハラボーイになったんじゃない
いわゆる食べ物はいっぱい
食べ物いっぱいあるんだよ
食べ物ないじゃないか
どうする？タバコに物を置ける家がないおばあさんがなんで食べ物いっぱいだよって言うのかと
これまたわからない うちは今日はちょっと申し訳ないんだよと言った方がわかりやすいでしょうね
うちは今日は何も用意したものはないんだよとかなんとか言えば
でもそういうのは失礼で
だから逆を言ってるみたいですね
食べるものはいくらでもありますよと
この村では だから心配しないでくださいというような意味で
そうするとそのお坊さんが次の家に行くという
だから家で食べ物はないっていうことを言わないで
気持ちとして気持ちで布施するんですよ
まあ村みんな同じ一緒だから
まあ自分の家は今日はもうアウトなんですけど
もうもうもうもう誰でもたくらむ
お布施したくて待ってますから
どうか心配しないでくださいとというふうな気持ちで
だから食べ物ないんだよということを一言お坊様に報告する時でも
そうやった時 すごい微妙に微妙に計算した単語まで出ているんです
だからその一言葉言ったおばあ様がもうお布施した布施徳を得ているんです
だから人のお布施に自分が気持ちで参加しているんだからね
たくさんもらってほしいというね
どうかみんななんかこのお坊様にお布施してくださいという気持ちを表しているんですね
で すごい簡単にあ 今日はお坊さん
うちはもうダメですよと言うと
もう自分にないことだけ表現するのであって
プラスアルファでいっぱいもらってほしいという気持ちは表現していないんですね
だからいっぱいもらってほしいという気持ちだけ言うんです
するとお坊さんがまたそこを計算して
そういうことはこの家は今日は何も用意していないんだということですと
そうするとお坊さんもその家にも祝福して
次の家に行ける そうやって信者さんが無いと言ったら
隣の家には行けます 来ないでくれと言ったらまあ断れる
また お母さんがおっぱいをあげてるんだったら
赤ちゃんのね で それだったらその家を飛ばしてもよろしいし
で 妊娠してかなりお腹が大きくて
もう結構大変で それでなんと軽々とどこかでもうやっと座って休んでるんだったらね
その家のお母さん その場合はもうなんか見てないような感じで次の家に行ってもよろしいと
なぜかっていうと お坊さんが来るともうお腹が重くて
もう疲れて座れてやっと横になってる時行ったら立てなくちゃいけないしね
そこはその体にとっては迷惑っていうこと
まあまあ それぐらいのケースですね
妊娠してもうすごい疲れてる時と
もうおっぱいあげてる時とかはまあ行かなくてもいいと
まあそこを微妙に微妙に
あの一言葉も喋ってはいけないところまでね
乞食じゃないんだよっていうところでね
よく覚えておけと そうするともう一言葉喋った方がもらいやすいんではない？だったらやめなさいと
挨拶ぐらい こんにちはとかなんとか言った方がいいんじゃないんでしょうかと
文句言うかもしれませんでしょ
家に行ってこんにちはとかね
ご飯ちょうだいではなくて
こんにちはぐらいはどうでしょう
いや ダメです そうするともらいやすい
だったらやめなさい もらいやすいというポイントじゃないんです
欲のない生き方をしているんだっていうことは大事なポイントで
物は買うて買うて食べるもんじゃないんだと
だから托鉢ながら釈迦族の習慣をギリギリギリと守る
で 微妙にでも借りを作ってはいけないんですね
こんにちは お元気ですかね
今はもう本当に不景気で大変でしょうねとか何かしゃべって
それで何かもらって帰るというともうそれはもう借り作ったことになっちゃうんですね
で 信者さんに徳が入ってないんです
いいお坊さんでよく挨拶もしてくれる
よく話してくれる それだけのことであげたんだから
仏法僧のために寄付お布施したことになってないんです
だから徳が壊されてますよ
信者さんが喜んでいるかもしれませんだけどね
だからお坊さんが泥をやってるんです
その場合 あげた側に無料の徳が入るはずでしたけど
例えばリンゴ 1個あげたかもしれませんだけど
どう元気ですかね まあこの頃不景気だからなかなかね
果物でもそんなに売れ行きは良くないでしょうねとかね
そうなんですね お坊さんがもう大変ですよとかね
せっかくお布施托鉢にいただいたんだけど
はい どうぞということであげちゃうでしょ
そうすると この挨拶を仲良く友達で喋ったことであげたんだからね
それでごく一般的なもう有言転義
だからあの信者さんにあのリンゴ 1個で無料の徳が入るはずでしたけどね
それはあのお坊さんがこんにちは
いかがでしょうかということで消えちゃったんです
だからそれが盗みっていうことにするんですよ
だからお坊さんがリンゴ 1個の借りを作るんです
何も言わず黙って出たところで
信者さんがもうじゃあこのリンゴで間に合わせちゃうかということで
お坊さんも何も言わずに帰ったならば
その人にもすごい無料の徳が入ってくるんです
そういう微妙にすごい難しい文化になってます
托鉢単純じゃないんです
[背景の雑音]